[Music]
hi players this is John boyega and this
is Star Wars Battlefront - whether
dominates in the multiplayer battle
front as kylo Ren leading your squadron
through thrilling dogfights in space
stepping into the boot of item version a
new single-player campaign the mastery
of skills in split-screen arcade this is
a starlit experience like none of the
player is greater depth and progression
than ever before
star wars battlefront 2 has nearly
tripled a number of locations and heroes
and vehicles as its predecessor it all
starts with the battlefront Kamino you
haven't formed wand or star killer base
and many more over 14 locations to
explore across all three star wars
errors
star wars battlefront 2 introduces class
gameplay choose from the assault heavy
specialists and officer classes each
with unique abilities weapons and weapon
attachments and give you an edge in
battle but it's not all about the power
of the individual the better you play
with your team the more battle points
you learn to call in powerful
reinforcement such as flame troopers or
walkies and a wide range of vehicles
both on the ground and in the air battle
points are also key to bringing iconic
Star Wars heroes into battle from Dark
Knight Bubba Fett right each hero has
unique abilities for you to customize
and master choose the right moments
calling your hero and turn the time
and last but not least we have
starfighters just by troopers each
Starfighter has a cloth and just like
battle points bring your favorite heroes
into battle they can also bring in your
favorite hero ships including the iconic
Millennium Falcon or with unique
handling and upgradeable abilities the
star card system has been completely
rebuilt these powerful collectables
exist for everything you can spawn in as
nothing to be as a trooper a vehicle
reinforcements or hero you can find them
in crates all craft and upgrade them
using parts the rarer the tier of card
the more powerful is effect in battle
choose the right star card for the right
situation get ready to fight
Star Wars Battlefront 2 contains five
different multiplayer modes lost
fast-paced close quarters combat strike
strategic objective based battles
heroes vs. villains where my chronic
Star Wars characters go head-to-head
star fighter Asami intense dogfights
across high atmosphere and space and
galactic assault epic 20 verse 20
all-out warfare not ready for
multiplayer and Co problem
bet your skills and try out all your
abilities offline play split-screen
co-op vs or solo and bound rewards Star
Wars Battlefront 2 single-player
campaign debuts an untold story The
Emperor's dead help him bridge the
events of The Return of the Jedi and the
force awakens so what happens now we
retired commander as item versio Special
Forces soldiers equally fall on the
ground as she is a space you'll fight
for the future of the Empire the galaxy
breaking apart
the few familiar faces along the way
it's up to you to rise as a new Star
Wars hero
star wars battlefront 2 is a massive one
and it's only getting bigger with a life
service that continues to evolve and
grow bringing new locations challenges
and characters such as Finn of course
and Captain phasma into the fray heroes
are born on the battlefront this holiday
jumping with me and begin your journey
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
sector is clear
Oh
[Music]
your next assignments they are
trying
you
[Music]
I've always been a fan of the darkside
the idea of the Imperial perspective is
you never really understand who they are
as people right or how the organization
works how can we distill that and how
can we make a story around that the
story of battlefront 2 is absolutely an
essential story what happened after
Return of the Jedi what happened to the
galaxy what happened to the Empire
without an emperor what it might feel
like to be in this galaxy is it starts
to break apart what's really exciting
about this story is that we're gonna see
it from the point of view of a character
like item so we're gonna see it from
this Imperial point-of-view Inferno
squad is a black ops team that most
people don't even know exists
we weren't expecting Special Forces we
happen to be on Endor when the second
death star explodes Ivan is presented
with an extreme challenge the
destruction of the Death Star - and the
death of the Emperor
what sort of choices would somebody in
that situation have to make about who
they are and what the galaxy was going
to become
and it's interesting does that mean now
that the Empire's fallen that they're
the underdogs
[Music]
iDEN is a tried and true and through and
through Imperial she's somebody who grew
up on a planet called far dos she was
very quickly put into a military camp
for children she has spent her whole
life building up to this moment to be
commander of Inferno squad I'm afraid
this inform the Admiral that I'm
precious indica precede his plan task is
the most zealous of them all I would say
he's the most interested and invested in
how far the Empire is willing to go he
was an orphan she needed something to
latch on to Empire his peace and justice
and order even when people are faltering
around him he pushes forward and says no
the Empire is the way I'm picking up
distress calls to many accounts
Bell has seen more of the galaxy than
most people in the Empire he actually
grew up on Coruscant during the time of
the Jedi he brings a lot of humor
Hindman I didn't have a bit of a banter
The Laugh family is a really important
element in Star Wars and one of the
things that we wanted to make sure we
captured is the dynamic between Garrick
versio and his daughter Ida and versio
this is the catalyst for iDEN where she
learns the future of the Empire and
she's elevated to a point by her father
we were next assignments they uh unusual
she's my daughter
she's all I have I do need for her to
understand why I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna do everything in Star Wars is
connected and part of our job is to make
sure that the games we're making do
connect back into that larger universe
but we're now able to use this game and
battlefront to as a resource to take
this information into future development
projects I think who those gamers out
there this is the culmination of all the
things that are good in the world
video games Star Wars and a team of
people that are willing to take the time
to do the work we have to take risks we
have to be bold we have to push
everyone's boundaries and leave a good
footprint behind
you
you